[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: To get started with the
Cloud Translation API for cURL,
you need a GCP project, which
you can set up in the Console.
Enable the Google
Cloud Translation
API for that project, and
then create a service account
and download the
private key as JSON.
You use these credentials
to access Google Cloud APIs.
So be sure to keep this file
secure and out of your code
and public repos.
To securely access the
credentials from your project,
go to the terminal, and
set an environment variable
to the path of your
service account.
If you don't yet have the Cloud
SDK installed on your machine,
then install and initialize it.
Instructions are linked below.
Use curl to make a request to
the translation.googleapis.com
endpoint.
The curl command includes JSON,
with the text to be translated,
the language to translate
from, and the language
to translate to.
The source and target
languages are identified
using the iso-639-1 codes.
The source language is
English-- in this case, en--
and the target language
is Spanish, es.
The format of the query is
noted as text, for plain text.
Run the curl command,
and you should
see this as your response.
Congratulations.
You have made your first request
with the Cloud Translation
API for cURL.
To find out more about
the client libraries
or consult translation
basics, check out
the Cloud documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]